from the academics point of view I think
you can you're sort of in touch with the
rhythms yeah walking through the parks
in Oxford or wherever it might be
no but it's a slightly different whereas
people who are you know who feel that
they are you know in in the center of
Westminster or Whitehall the view from
there is one of constant crisis
management for lots and lots of
different different reasons and so a lot
of the issues that have emerged well
because with all due respect tend to
think they're incredibly important no
they do they do but all politicians do
yes they do and it might well be that
actually when those the waves are
breaking there's nothing that you or
your colleagues could do to stand in the
way you know and in fact at the moment
how I see it in the world we talked a
little bit about outside I built it's
not a discussion about Europe for me
what is important to in today's world in
2016
the future of Europe is a sideshow yes
in a much much bigger picture of where
change is happening and we have no
engagement at all there's a discussions
about the 23rd of June about how and
what world of Russia the Middle East
Iran China Pakistan and India 80 of the
world's populations sure you're
absolutely right and I think that that
is a product of the straight jacket of
our education it's because MPS are
always worrying about crisis management
yes it's always trying to mop up the
what did Michael Gove say about experts
on TV and how do you back out of it
without sort of being elegant and stop
cheap shots and that's that's not the
point of it but I think that that
walking around the parks that world that
you talk of funnily enough I think I
have a greater level of responsibility
than an MP no no because if you get this
wrong if you don't present your ideas
entirely accurately entirely rightly
there is no back out of I just made a
mistake or let me clarify you put you're
part of your soul on a page you let
yourself be judged by your academic
communities in the national press
International presses and it has to
actually stack up you have to double
your research you can't guess what's
going to happen in the future
this book isn't about what's going to
happen it's about how we've reached
where we are but this is where the in
terms of the process of the mindset it's
a very different thing because and you
said you're quite right I mean
politicians think they're self-important
all the rest of it but the kind of
mindset that they have given the 24 7
media given the um constituency
constraints and and and that
um uh pressure means that the way in
which they approach problems is very
different agreed so are there any other
are there any other MPS apart from quasi
here tonight
um
I can tell you the number of approaches
I've had and contact with Chinese
government Governor Pakistan Kazakhstan
Central Asian States sure uh other
governments in Europe yeah and this in
in the UK I'd be very surprised or
interested to know how many of your
colleagues have read the book but I
don't get my phone doesn't ring for
Westminster they wouldn't because
because because the the British
political
um system is notoriously uh focused on
the short term for lots and lots of
reasons yes lots of historical reasons
and you will you're much more likely to
get a reader of your book frankly in
Berlin or Rome among the political class
that would be the case in London and I
think that's a great shame but but from
from the point of view of of someone who
is involved in uh politics you've got a
situation in which the British public
is probably the least differential uh in
the world you've got a an a a media
which was described by Tony Blair as a
feral media
um and um you've got a situation in
which
um I mean let's be frank you know people
working in the public sector
broadcasting you know Jeremy Paxman or
whoever is you know earning five times
as much as the Prime Minister I mean in
terms of the power and the influence yes
because I mean then read it again not as
an MP because if you want to if you want
to say proper Hatchet Jobs go and read
accounts of sixth Century called certain
opal no I'm not I'm not I don't complain
about Jeremy person
1500 years that sounded awful I mean I
wasn't trying to make a difference I was
just trying to describe a media world
and a medium the media world as a
historian that just means the sources
that doesn't mean any I mean there are
you guys you are always held up to um
I'm not complaining about scrutiny and
I'm not complaining about
um I'm not I'm just describing a world
in which the media in Britain it the
fourth estate islamor commentators we
call accommodators um why is that
different from later the Chinese court
or I think it's a slightly different
because the Byzantine emperor and
certainly the Chinese emperor they could
if they got very cross you know get your
head chopped off was I don't think that
David Cameron quite has those Powers
um I'm sure he would like to have them
but but but it's a very different
um you know dynamic of power I mean what
I wanted to move on to was was precisely
this question of but to be to be fair
you know we do we do you know we do do
that with the BBC we've cut we've shut
down the Russian service of the BBC
which is which has been a hugely
damaging uh hugely damaging to save
peanuts in the grand scheme of things I
mean I think your point and you know
it's about the death of democracy is
also something that you know I want to
bring in here is that you're absolutely
right about planning for tomorrow the
emergency and that's a real challenge I
don't I don't have any doubt how
difficult the day-to-day life of an MPS